Hong Kong is cleaning up after an
anniversary spiraled into chaos and
violence demonstrators stormed the
city's main government office building
on Monday many of them say China's
government is taking away their unique
freedoms ramie innocencio is covering
the protests good morning Hong Kong woke
up as a city more divided than ever many
are blaming the protesters for the
latest chaos but many others are blaming
Beijing and China's Communist Party
hundreds of young angry protesters broke
into Hong Kong's legislature Monday
spray-painting anti-government slogans
on walls and defacing the city's symbol
they occupied the chamber demanding to
be heard by a government they don't
trust they want their leaders to revoke
a contentious extradition bill and for
the city's top leader to resign their
demands that their government revoke a
bill that could let Beijing extradite
anyone from Hong Kong and for the city's
top leader to resign after midnight the
government acted riot police swept the
area firing several rounds of teargas
and clashing with protesters injuring
about 50 in a pre-dawn press conference
chief executive Carrie Lam condemned the
violence and called for a return to
normalcy but for many Monday's chaos was
the culmination of years of growing
anger I think is a wake-up call for both
Carrie Lam and much more so the central
government they need to understand that
behind them this is something much more
fundamental much of a higher order the
Communist Party in Beijing today said it
stands behind the government here in
Hong Kong and says that anyone who
stormed the legislature will be
prosecuted ramie Inocencio CBS this
morning Hong Kong